Boom!
♪♪
(Giggling)
Huzzah!
♪♪
(Wolf howling)
Carol:
I know you're all anxious to go
home,
Carol:
but we have some
housekeeping to take care of first.
You received a packet.
You're instructed to sign that
packet and return it to me.
So, let's just be reasonable
adults and sign our packets so
we can all go home.
Sound good?
(All)
Mmm... No no no
(All complaining)
♪♪
David:
We have a meeting with Montreal
next week.
Where are we with the expansion?
We've been working really well
together.
Boom!
David:
I've seen this pattern before.
It's the calm before the
divorce.
We are not your parents.
I was talking about my own
divorce.
Hmm.
-Although both apply actually.
(Sighs)
♪♪
I have a Masters in fine arts.
Wow. We didn't ask for a
podcast.
Ian:
That's what I was gonna say.
I was gonna say. I don't need to
hear your podcast.
-There's just so much information.
I feel like we're on the same
page, we're really vibing about
it. -We kind of are.
Something bad is gonna happen.
♪♪
Here we go.
(Tires screech) (Gears grind)
I can drive stick.
Okay.
-I, My legs are probably to
strong and I'm putting to much...
Yeah, that's probably it.
♪♪
(Howls)
David:
The high pressure and the
friction...
Ba-Bahh, baby!
David:
...that's what turns coal into
diamonds.
Huzzah!
-Laughing
Yo, what's up, Snoop?
Aight, man, when you releasing
that new expansion?
When you release that new
album?
-Chuckles.
You look very cute.
In that MoCap suit?
-This MoCap suit?
You like this side?
(Laughter) Yeah!
(Sighs)
♪♪
C.W.:
Oh, how I wish I could be with
you.
To press flesh against
flesh.
Okay, well you know.
-Nope nope.
It's better that he's remote.
I'm gonna hangup.
♪♪
That shirt is so tight that I
can authentically see your
nipples.
Why are you looking at my
nipples?
It's hard not to, you're kind of
asking for it!
That's victim blaming. You can't
blame me.
You are a victim of nothing!
♪♪